[Music]
just over 10 years ago i did a movie
called old dogs it was a disney movie
starring john travolta and
the real reason i did the movie robin
williams i wanted to be around him i
wanted to share a scene with him and i
got to it was a thrill of a lifetime and
i'm just forever grateful for that
experience and robin what really struck
me about it was
how open robin was
uh with the rest of the crew
and with the background actors he was
constantly doing his characters he was
doing popeye and mrs doubtfire it was
really
he was just so giving of his talents and
my mom and dad and my grandma jody
listeners will know got to come and
visit and it was the first time they got
to see me at work
with somebody that they knew so it was
really that was also a thrill an icon
a true icon yeah and robin and and
travolta both took so much of their time
talked to my parents were just could not
have been kinder and more generous with
their time
and uh i'll never forget that what a
loss i miss him i me too life could be a
dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long sorry about that
downer note life could be a dream
sweetheart
but really uplifting because he gave us
so much um
and here's someone else who gives me a
lot oh and probably some of you
christian long my brother
i had to do a slight little bit of uh
acrobatics to for that pivot it was
impressive it was very impressive
it is strange though to miss someone
that you've never met i've never met him
and i feel like i miss him well i don't
that's how important he was yeah i know
my life growing up to like to my
entertainment he entertained me so much
right that i miss i feel like i know him
well i miss him the way you do and i
because i
knew him so briefly and not not well
enough to miss him in that way but um
this is very braggy but i ran into his
daughter
months later maybe a year after his
death and
zelda zelda yeah very cool zelda and uh
she she said that he had said nice
things about me really flattered
to me yeah it was really nice
yeah i just loved his like you i mean i
miss him i i loved
him i loved he was just brilliant it's i
mean it's a very difficult thing i think
to be able to accomplish to to evoke
that in strangers
that like i missed i mean i'm really
mourning like to mourn a person you've
never interacted with is is like this i
mean now what's happening
i know i uh i never met chadwick and
i've i only heard the best things but
the nicest things about him but um
yeah i miss him as well i'll miss him
and you think about the the work of his
that
that
our world will miss will be deprived of
it's
it's such a death it's impressive though
in both their cases that they left this
legacy this um
what what a great gift they gave the
world you know yeah and
rob cat i can't wait to read that book
david scoff wrote a book uh about robin
williams that is next up from me i i'm
really looking forward to reading it so
you're gonna dive in like 2022. yes
uh yeah post it'll be a post-pandemic
read
uh but anyway why are we talking about
sorry this is a little bit of a downer
uh but that it shouldn't be a downer it
should be uplifted they're both uh we
were lucky to have them
and they were both just really beautiful
artists and and icons
christian were talking about how uh a
friend of ours just over overuses that
word a lot of people overuse that word
it's become uh
it's like the new lit literally oh yeah
so they'll be like so he basically said
all of my
other people follow me on instagram are
icons and uh
and it's not true by the way sarah
doesn't follow him um
there are icons but you have to reserve
that our point was that you have to
reserve that word or else it loses its
meaning that word has now been hijacked
by popular culture and now it's been
diluted to the point where
you can't describe share as an icon
anymore because then people would be
like oh my my friend's an icon too
so my my friend and cher have a lot in
common by the way that was an iconic
thing for you to say how so it was just
well said it was a decent uh
like eloquently like stated
it was iconic am i an icon no
no but like
you know i i think part of being an icon
uh obviously you have to be significant
whatever we're not the arbiters of who
or who isn't an icon but i do know this
i know that all of our friend keith's
friends aren't icons right and here's
another thing i know our guest today
is an icon
it's difficult to argue against that our
and and as well as the co-star um of
robin williams in one of his most iconic
roles
uh in the birdcage our guest today is
icon nathan lane uh nathan is known for
well the bird cage but mouse hunt
uh oh you led with mouse hunt really no
no it's great movie i would say he's
most known for the producers the
producers guys and dolls yeah well i'm
hung up on some of those things i was
really listening to the uh
the lion king of course he voices the uh
meerkat named named uh
uh oh don't i know it i know i don't
know it um ah i can hear him saying
timon timon is that it yeah oh i almost
said that timon where is it tim
i think it's tim timon you know i should
ask him yeah oh [ __ ] too late uh yes he
is a famous meerkat
the most famous i would say and he uh he
graced us with his presence today it was
cool to i had met him once only briefly
years ago at a reading of a play called
the nance
which he did on broadway and i did not
do
i don't remember why but uh it was i'm
just such a fan of his and um you got
recast by an icon maybe maybe yeah like
ben platt took over our guest today is
uh
is i would say he's both a sir and a
dame i would i think he qualifies yeah
that's fair because you know we live in
a time where gender's fluid and his i
would say most iconic or one of his most
iconic roles was
would you call that character in the
bird cage i don't know he played a drag
queen drag queen i don't know is that
going of course you can say drag queen
okay all right yes you play drag queen
yes queen
and um
and by the way our friend keith we
should say i wonder if he listens we
don't have to talk about that all right
he played a drag queen in that movie and
he
i i think it may be in the top five or
ten most brilliant comedic performances
i've ever seen yeah in a movie it's
amazing yeah as much as we love uh robin
williams as brilliant like once robin
williams let's face it he's a
once-in-a-lifetime entertainer he is a
charlie chaplin of our time
and uh
so in it so in order to like steal any
sort of the spotlight from
robin williams you know it's got to be
that's a high bar that is that is a that
is a big ask for a performer and he's
the funniest part of that movie and that
movie is really funny and there's
legends in that movie like nichols
directed it gene hackman diane wiese
it's like elaine may wrote it i mean it
is it's just such a masterfully done
comedy and he yeah he's the
he's
i mean he's like the reason he's the
funniest part so uh back to 2020 for a
second nathan is in penny dreadful city
of angels now on showtime where he plays
a hardened la detective
which is very difficult to imagine but
he's so versatile as an actor that i'm
sure he pulls that off yeah i can see
that especially having talked to him if
i hadn't
well let's hear it okay and see what you
guys think about uh his prospects for
playing a hardened detective in what
1930s 20s sounds cool uh anyway here
this hopefully sounds cool as well to
you this interview with
an interview does that sound like i'm
giving it more interview it's an
interview okay with the iconic
nathan lane
life could be a dream
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge watching low
budget made for tv holiday movies the
all-new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wondering plus in the wondery app
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
well you know nathan the show's more
about uh
yeah i know you're going to find out
what makes me tick yeah why not
thousands of therapists weren't able to
do it why not you
got an hour well i already know that
you're indifferent to doing press so
that's interesting we're chipping away
at it who's thrilled about that except
for maybe kristin chenoweth who is
actually she's thrilled about everything
to talk to the press oh oh really oh i
should have i should have asked her to
do this
uh no no but uh well then this would be
like a relief for you nathan because you
won't have to talk about the show
no
that's the only reason i'm here
i've been meaning to catch up after that
play reading at lincoln center yeah yeah
we did a reading you know it's funny
last time i saw you it was that was for
the nance uh this really great douglas
carter bean play and it keeps coming up
for some reason on this one i know why
on this show we've been discussing the
difference between my brother and i saw
the wizard of oz a couple weeks ago and
we had morocco on and mo pointed out the
the the trope uh in in pop culture of
the zanies in um
in like the 50s and 60s i think it was i
think it was akin to the anand's
character the zanies have you heard this
yeah it's like charles nelson
charles nelson reilly or paul lind
well yeah i mean i suppose i have has
the podcast started are we actually
doing this now yeah i guess so yeah i i
never
it there's no real okay and here we're
rolling
oh okay
so so mind what you say yeah
well i really will let's start with i
was being pretty working fast and loose
there
but that's good i thought it was just
the two of us but now that i know
um
well you know there was
i mean i i hate to jump right into this
the what was called the pans he crazed
yeah
well this is a perfect lead in the 20s
uh
where there was there was a kind of
subculture where people would go to
clubs in the village and and
and there were a lot of gay performers
and it was you know it was like
everything before the the uh the haze
code in hollywood you know when they
started to put all these restrictions
yeah uh on films and uh
so and then yeah it was sort of after
prohibition things got uptight and and
uh but yes if there was they did refer
to that as the pansy cranes
the zany's craze i think that was that
was just they were victims of of the
homophobia at the time
and and people like i mean charles
nelson riley i i you know i know he's
sort of become a punchline but he was a
really
incredibly witty and smart guy if you've
ever seen they did a film of his one-man
show the life of riley oh really
incredibly funny and really really
interesting about what he went through
um you know
you know studio television studio
executive sitting him down and saying we
don't want [ __ ] in television oh wow you
will you will never work in television
and of course he had a huge career in
television but he was also a brilliant
director and he directed many broadway
shows uh very often with julie harris um
you know one of his close friends and he
was uh is it
is that amazing nathan that somebody can
now history can reduce somebody to that
as you said a punchline i mean you know
a lot of people do an impression of him
and oh he's he's known on hollywood
squares but that somebody could live
such a rich artistic life and
yeah i mean he was more look they the
everyone everyone gets uh stereotyped to
agree
and certainly he that's what was
available to him and that
he played that character many times uh
not unlike franklin pengborn in the
movies in the 30s
but yeah he was i think he was a much
more talented actor uh than that
and uh and i really i mean he was just
one of the most entertaining people in
the world but
well it felt like that he didn't get to
branch out more
yeah i i'm so interested one of the
reasons i loved that play doing that
reading aside from just being in a
reading with you was um
that that subject really fascinates me
that there were so many great performers
who were not completely silenced but
certainly um minimized by the the
cultural
uh
restrictions of the time and um i talked
to recently leslie jordan about this and
leslie
uh who who is
it's hard for leslie to mask his
sexuality i mean leslie is quite
flamboyant but leslie's just i mean it's
hard to get away and he was telling me
about in the beginning of his career
the different words they would use the
agents and the studio people to quell
that behavior um
you're too soft or whatever d did you
you must have seen a
huge change i mean in your in your
career in your lifetime when it comes to
that when it came you know
um i mean
i i don't know what goes on behind
closed doors what people might have said
about me or anybody else um
i would think that
not as much as you might think or hope
um i think it still goes on yeah yeah
that uh people
you know have issues with that um
but um
yeah i mean
in terms of the play the nance um
dog carter bean will be thrilled we're
talking so much about the play
um
but it was the notion really was i mean
he took a character that in in in
burlesque was a minor character that
would pop
from time to time and made him sort of
the central character of that story
right
you know to explore not only you know
the politics of that time but but uh gay
life at that time and
and what it was like for someone who's
been constantly told from
the day he was born that you don't fit
in and how does that affect his mindset
yeah it was this sort of
ultimately very sad love story yeah
mixed in with a kind of cabaret like
where you know you see scenes from the
the the sketches yes the burlesque house
and then
uh scenes from his real life which were
very serious and and that juxtaposition
how traditional was your own upbringing
i mean you grew up in new jersey
um did you have a fairly typical would
you say suburban upbringing oh
no oh
no no no no no
no okay uh uh
i grew up in jersey city
um yeah i i have two older brothers dan
bob um uh there's a big age difference i
was i was born
uh my mother was 40 when she had one it
was blatant life
births it's so totally unplanned wow and
uh i think they went to a wedding and
had a little too much to drink
hey here you are things got crazy in
here on you
uh so um
you know and at that point um
not to go into too much excruciating
detail but
um essentially my father uh who was not
a drinker uh in his life he had been a
truck driver and then he got a job
working for the city is a
somehow i don't know how he got the job
as a court clerk or something and
and um he started drinking and he became
uh
a raging alcoholic uh
and then um
he essentially drank himself to death
and
sort of the year before my mother moved
us to another apartment she finally left
him after years of urging him to join
alcoholics anonymous which he would from
time to time and then
it would he would always go back to
drinking and then uh
so within a period of about three years
she her her mother passed away my
grandmother who really sort of was the
the matriarch of the family and looked
and minded me a lot while my mother was
working she had a job as a secretary at
the prosecutor's office in germany
and
so that was a huge blow and then and
then within a year of moving away my
father drank himself to death and then
she had a breakdown and for several
years was in and out of uh hospitals
mental institutions they
eventually it was diagnosed as manic
depression or what we now call bipolar
um so
uh it was
um so i had to grow up fat very quickly
yeah and were your brothers around for
this nathan were they my mother's
illness was all happening sort of during
my high school years my formative years
so
um they would have done anything to get
out of the house they both got married
and and they were there uh to help but i
was living alone with her and which was
going through these different stages of
of manic depression and literally where
she would be uh depressed and suicidal
for months at a time and then she would
go to a hospital and get medication and
they would say oh we think it's she has
a hyperactive thyroid
and
then she would come out and she would be
in a very manic stage and she would wear
mini skirts and and buy a lot of things
that we didn't need
she plotted long distance calls and get
very vigilant and then she would go away
again and then she came back and then
she got very paranoid and and uh it was
very
very difficult
until finally
there was an incident
where she caused a scene at a church
um
i can laugh now it wasn't funny at the
time i'm only laughing because you're
laughing by the way you gave me license
time i know well it's always it helps
yeah
yeah but
she caused this scene at a church i i
won't go into the whole thing but
by the way you're free to oh yeah i know
how much time do we have oh
weeks yeah uh
anyway but finally at a at a hospital
and we we had moved from jersey city to
rutherford new jersey
a pastoral
like bucolic yes motherboard new jersey
thinking a change of pace might help
closer to the landfill many moods
uh uh finally
in this
i think was called it was bergen pines
hospital they said she's she has manic
depression and then she was put on
lithium
and that that
changed her life
if i mean i'm guessing for the better it
it so it balanced her out
yeah
yeah
it's right um were you present for that
for the display in the church were you
there did you witness no it was one of
those things uh where i woke up and she
was gone and then my brothers my brother
my oldest brother dan came and said she
she had a thing oh this is really
delving too deeply into all this but she
when she was young and and she was
married to my father and he went off to
war
she had i won't say it was an affair but
there was a young it's like a summer
tennessee williams fanny hearst novel
she had a kind of relationship with this
young guy who was studying for the
priesthood
um and she
was uh and she sort of fell in love with
him and then he but
he
wouldn't leave he was a devout he
thought about it i guess you know they
couldn't get together yeah because of
this although there was i guess she was
the talk of the neighborhood because he
would visit a lot oh my god it's a real
forbidden fruit so many years now later
and she's an older woman and she's um
having this episode in a church and she
for some reason apparently thought the
guy the priest on the alter one this guy
um i won't mention it exactly no no
that's okay
he's probably not listening family
members um
but she was you know she kind of had on
it like a raincoat over her nightgown
and she lit up a cigarette
and barreled down the aisle of the
church during like a high mass or
something and started screaming at the
priest
you know
calling his name and saying you know
you can't you know you can't hide from
me anymore you're forsaken whatever yeah
yeah whatever it was oh my god and that
that sort of led to her
to her
oh wow but but
it's fascinating that it was connected
to something very powerful in her life
um
yeah wow so so you were raised catholic
nathan at this point are you you're
still practicing when you're in high
school no no oh practicing yeah
practicing right right
you're all practical practice makes
perfect
yeah and uh then we found out it wasn't
so perfect
um no i i i abandoned catholicism
not long after
why it's hard for me to imagine you not
being
a gregarious entertaining kid
were you and and
if so was that was do you think that had
anything to do was that a coping
mechanism that you developed uh i could
be and i i was at times uh and
definitely it was a coping mechanism it
was a defense mechanism uh uh for sure
yeah uh
i felt safe that way yeah and um and i
didn't have to talk about myself or my
you know my family or
any stuff that was going on right oh yes
i got involved in in school plays and
and uh was you know a bit of a class
clown not so much a troublemaker i think
i i was a pretty good student but stamp
but i would certainly
yes yeah i could be entertaining you
knew that was a strength
yes during her
i'll just call them good periods was
your mother supportive of that was your
and prior to his death was your father i
i read that he was an aspiring singer
himself
was that something that's
that's what they've told me
okay
that's the that's delayed
i don't remember much singing in the
house whether that's true or not whether
a hollywood talent scout came to town
and
um
right wanted to take them that's what
they would tell me uh-uh i'm gonna take
him to hollywood and become a hufflepuff
that's funny an
[Laughter]
warner brothers i don't know yeah but um
uh
yes he didn't really
uh
live to see um any of any of that yeah
in high school my mother was very yes
very supportive and and uh sure they all
you know we were dysfunctional they love
show business
that's perfect they couldn't wait for
someone to make it
it's right
bills
yeah so and did you aspire to do that
during the during that period when you
were in high school was that something
that you knew you were good at
it was
yes it was something i was good at and
that i obviously had a need to perform
uh
whatever that was uh because really i
was i was really shy and not not bad at
all but it was some sort of i guess it
was some sort of release yeah what i was
going through yeah i'm sure and uh
um and i also enjoyed the the the
camaraderie and the working together
with people yeah and being and having
fun
but uh um
uh uh i didn't think of it as a
profession so much
until later until towards the end of
high school where i thought maybe i
actually could do this it was really my
brother my oldest brother dan who
was uh sort of played a parental role
and and was a father figure who
certainly encouraged me to read a great
deal and also interest in the theater he
took me to the theater he was a teacher
and he would take me along with his
classes to see plays and so that's
really what sparked all of that and so i
think he was seeing um
things on broadway or off-broadway that
he took me to that led me to think you
know i would love to do that and perhaps
i could yeah
whoever's i'm wondering who were some of
your those inspirations the real
formative oh i want to be like that
person
as you are now to so many young
performers uh
well um
you know i we
you know it was jackie gleason yeah yeah
yeah
um
i think maybe i sensed a kindred spirit
yeah yeah you know also came from
extreme poverty uh a horrendous sort of
childhood and you know abandoned by uh
his father when he was
very young
and it's a
rather dickensian dramatic story a
chaplain too yeah that gleeson's father
uh had this elaborate plan and he went
through all the family photos and cut
his picture out of them oh my god so
that when when it was when she or his
mother was waiting for him to come from
work and getting his paycheck and it was
literally it was like christmas time and
he had disappeared and when she went to
show
photos to the police
she had no photos of him oh my god and
they never found him
um holy [ __ ] i didn't know and many many
years later after he had become jackie
gleason came out of the woodwork he had
become this icon of television the most
successful uh certainly the highest paid
performer in television
he had someone look for him
and they found him so he had the
opportunity to meet with him and
one and and they and they told him where
he was he was working on a farm oh my
god and he said um
no never mind
the the father said no no no no
wow wow decided not to meet with him you
know
nathan i'm i'm struck by how often
this theme comes up and the people i
talk to the people whom i admire uh they
have had you know oftentimes difficult
dysfunctional upbringings um
do you ever think about if your
childhood if that had circumstances had
been different you may have been led
somewhere else or you may not have been
so driven to do what you do i could be
an accountant today yes yeah a very
successful one it might if it hadn't
been so [ __ ] up i don't know you know
marty short you know
one of the the greatest
rapes um
uh had a very happy childhood although
there was the sadness in his family
there was deaths in his yes i read his
book but i think you know he was very
happily brought up and
you know so
so you can turn out
from happiness as well but yes it does
seem to be a pattern that many times
people who come from
different family situations
that wind up in the arts life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
[Music]
i imagine you know martin short well
that you guys together must be just
incredibly entertaining uh how often do
you see him are you close with him
everyone wants to be close tomorrow yeah
i bet um i did see him when i was uh in
l.a i was in l.a for seven months making
uh uh penny dreadful city of angels so
uh my husband and i had a a wonderful
dinner with him and and you know we talk
on the phone from time to time but he's
you know he's also been just very busy
with he and steve martin right they've
been touring literally touring up to the
last minute before the the shutdown yes
in ireland and england doing their their
show which is
hilarious
yeah is this your first season on penny
dreadful yes this is the first season
yes it's a brand new iteration under the
penny dreadful title the one that josh
hartnett had previously starred in
that's right and and that's a whole new
cast
you're self-included you can't wait to
talk about it
um yeah um uh just to go back really
quick uh when you did then nathan decide
to pursue
theater acting uh
did you move directly to new york was
that was that the path that seemed most
obvious i received a um a drama
scholarship to uh this place saint
joseph's college in philadelphia
i i can remember auditioning for it and
getting this drama scholarship we had no
money for college and so i was getting a
government loan and student loans in
this scholarship and then i went uh to
the first day i had my bags were put in
the room
and um i went in and they told me
that i owed them more money i was going
to have to take out another loan to help
pay for college and uh i guess i found
this very upsetting this is a long time
ago and my brother dan was with me and
he could see how upset i was and he said
well listen you know there's no law that
says you have to go to college right now
you could take some time off get a job
and work and make some money so you're
not concerned about all these
student loans
and i said okay
let's go got my bags i went home and
then someone some sinister family
connection got me a job
as a bail interviewer at the seventh
precinct in jersey city bail interviewer
bail interviewer in which i would do the
paperwork for the court clerk and uh to
see if the person being arrested could
be uh released on their own recognizance
and i would have to fill out the
paperwork so people who are being
arrested
one to me
and i would have to ask them you know if
they owned any real estate
oh my god talk about character study and
uh i did this for about a month and then
i had previously worked for a little
non-equity theater company at the half
penny playhouse that was in residence at
uh upsala college in east orange new
jersey
and they put together a little musical
review
for the upcoming bicentennial
uh about the history of new jersey
called jurors j-e-r-z
and so that was sort of my first theater
job out of oh
it's like waiting for guffman it's a
little like waiting for gotham yeah and
we toured all over the state
doing doing uh this little musical
and uh every day playing to children
and um
but professional i mean technically
you're making money doing it yes i was
making money and then and then
eventually i got my equity card because
they also put together a musical review
about the metric system because
because the there was that some there
was talk of perhaps america was going to
go metric
of course we could never do that
you know we could never unless the show
is ahead people won't stay inside let
alone learn the metric system
so uh uh but that would be a good time a
musical review called one for good
measure
that's how i got my actors equity card
and by then i had moved
from rutherford to manhattan and i read
when that happened there was a joseph
lane right there was already a joseph
there was a there was already a joseph
lane in actors equity and uh they said
you're gonna have to change
your name and i i said oh uh and and
they said you can take some time to
think about it
and i said no just give me a minute
i went and i sat on a bench and um and i
had done
at that point i had done some summer
stock non-equity summer stock
uh i worked at a place called the uh
what was it the mack hayden theater
in chatham upstate new york chatham new
york and yeah they did musicals uh eight
musicals in eight weeks
yes it's near the red barn is it the red
barn maybe now i don't know i don't know
whether it still exists or what happened
but it's um so i did i had worked there
and i done a lot of shows and so i uh
and and i had also done a non-equity
production of guys and dolls
where i had played nathan detroit
and uh i think i was 21 at the time
and uh so i i
had always loved this character of
nathan detroit and i liked the name and
so i i said okay i'll be nathan lane
oh my god it's got a great ring to it uh
and then how thrilling nathan was it to
play that part on broadway years later
um yeah unbelievable uh a dream come
true that that happened because i i
really i so love that show
uh
i just think it's one of the
maybe greatest musical ever written
and so it was um yeah i i uh yeah it's
it's an amazing
thing that that happened who does call
you joseph still or joe my brother my
brothers call dan
yeah yeah i mean occasionally they'll
say
nathan
it must be weird for them um you know
there's like quotation marks around it
when they
maybe when they think you're being like
too much of an actor or a diva you're
nathan
yeah but yeah no they still call me joe
how quickly once you're in new york do
things start happening and are you
nervous i mean i know you have your
equity card and all that and you've done
summer stuff you've been making money
doing acting but but i i imagine you you
know not that quickly
at all
you know i can remember kind of starving
sharing an apartment
uh with a woman i had worked with in
summer stock
um
uh
you know sleeping in the living room
and and uh you know i can remember
coming home
there was a like a market a fruit market
you know
and like stealing a
a grapefruit i was hungry
a blueberry
blueberry
you know i was doing odd jobs like in
telegrams and phone
oh you did singing telegram selling
things by phone you know tv guide the
little it was a thing called the bull
worker that was sort of the isometric
thing you you know for your for your
chest nathan is miming i have to tell
everyone this this move yes no i'm doing
this
so um but it was a plastic thing you
went like you had to sell that i imagine
you'd be good at that i had
my phone i had to do harris polls
surveys so i uh you know i i did things
a little off off broadway things but
uh uh
what yeah it took a long time and what
happened was um
at a certain point i had done a little
off off broadway
review and i worked with this guy named
patrick stack and and people thought we
were funny together and you know this is
when comedy was about to become the rock
and roll
of the of the uh 80s or what i i believe
so um
we uh put an act again and then we were
seen by someone at william morris and
then we went to l.a
and uh
did the merv griffin show no kidding as
a yeah as a comedy duo as a comedy duo
didn't go so well
uh but we did we did this showcase at
the comedy store and uh um and so
i mean we were never thinking oh we want
to be the next uh martin and lewis but
we
we thought as actors it might lead to
something yeah and it certainly was
for a period of three years i think it
was or four years it was a great
learning experience
having to get up on stage and and and
present you this product that you have
you so i became a writer and a director
and and uh and you learn very quickly
what works and doesn't work when you
have when you're opening for
eddie rabbit in petaluma
you know and you have no billing and
they just say and but before eddie the
comedy style
and people have timed their drugs for
eddie and so it's very upset yeah it's a
tough audience yeah so you learned very
quickly and then what happened was i uh
we were out in la for about a year year
and a half and i auditioned for a sitcom
for nbc that they were going to shoot in
new york it was starring mickey rooney
oh my god and and dana carvey
um called one of the boys so i went back
to new york
uh i auditioned and i got this job and
then we shot 13 episodes in new york
well mickey rooney was making uh sugar
babies oh my god doing sugar babies at
night and then in his spare time during
the day he thought he'd squeeze in
what was what was that like what was he
like nathan
oh no
not him
you know never grew up yeah right he was
he was um yes you're talking about
damage
right you know the studio system mgm
you know just i mean he was an
incredibly talented person yeah
and um he was having this renaissance
because of sugar babies and the the
black stallion right i remember a bunch
of disney movies he was doing
he was nominated for that and he um
you know he incredibly gifted when he
put his mind to it
but this sitcom was sort of you know it
was not very good
and and i we sort of knew that going in
and um and so it was an interesting mix
of personalities
dana who is you know brilliant guy bro
this is pre-snl
dane yes
yes
and um
and you know mickey didn't quite
understand him yeah
and can you do an impression of mickey
not understanding dana
uh uh well he just sort of was he was
suspicious of dana and and and and i
think because dana was sort of was thin
and blonde and slightly flamboyant he
thought dana was gay
but
dana had a girlfriend who eventually
he's been and he's been married
now for you know i don't know how many
years but
uh paula but they
he um yeah and dana used to say why
don't you tell him your day he thinks
monday and i would say there's no reason
for me to break america's sweethearts
hearts
uh to know that i'm gay when this is we
know this is not going beyond 13.
perhaps it was the second season i might
sit down don't throw me under the gay
buzz
so anyway uh um but look it was it was
it was
you know it was great because it got me
back to new york and i made it i made a
little bit of money and and uh it and
that sort of led to me
um uh i i
i was with william morris at the time
and i kept saying to them um
uh why not you know i'd like to go out
for theater that's really what i do and
and and the guy said you just did a
series why would you want to do theater
and this is the head of the theater
department tootsie so
so i left
william morris and i went with an agent
called jeff hunter and he sent me out on
an audition for a revival of the noel
tower play present laughter that george
c scott was going to star in and
directed
and circle in the square so this is
around 1982
and that was my broadway debut oh my god
with george c scott jesus god
you go from mickey roundy to rooney to
george c scott uh
so does this put the kibosh on the uh
stack and lane act well uh pat wanted to
stay in los angeles he loved los angeles
uh neither one of us uh uh was looking
for
you know to be
the the next big comedy team we were
hoping it would lead to acting jobs and
which it did
and he really wanted to stay out there
so it yes it did it was the demise of
second lane we
we had gotten we had a holding deal
for a bit
uh they they were lenny and squiggy were
threatening to leave and
they wanted to back up
you're not kidding
no i'm not kidding
that's what we were told and so we had a
holy deal with them and then nothing
came of it and i stayed in new york and
he stayed in l.a and we're friends to
this day so now you're you're working
with george c scott at this point you
have to be i'm always interested in when
people became
uh
confident found their confidence in
doing this um oh well i'm still doing it
yeah okay yeah but
marty snort is the only one i know
he's not worried about annie really
really yeah god god well i i assume that
only because of your
you always seem so uh connected to what
you're doing and so present and and i
and i think well as an actor i try to
yeah but uh confident
no i mean you know i you know you i
maybe i can put on a good act at times
no i think you always it's such a
a strange
craft
it's such there's so much you know
there's all this work that goes into it
and sort of research
and and being prepared for whatever
emotional stuff you may have to do but
you know and then there's this other
element that just is is about instinct
and and uh
i you know i never quite know no one
does
how it's gonna go you hope you hope that
after
at least as doing it as long as i have
that you have a technique yeah you have
but you know hoping for inspiration to
strike like in the theater night after
night it doesn't work that way it's just
there is magic eight times a week
nathan when it doesn't strike are you
able to shake it off pretty easily or do
you dwell on it do you does it sit with
you
oh i'm sure i'll i'm oh i'm always happy
to dwell on it
yeah yeah oh okay yeah uh um yeah i
can't remember the all the good stuff
but the the bad absolutely yeah
absolutely
and and um
you know you try not to blame the
audience and it's sort of like what why
did that happen why is that
you know and it's it's it's tough eight
shows a week is is really a hard hard
work especially it's this i'm thinking
of some of the shows you've done with
some guys and dolls you mentioned the
funny thing happened on the word of the
producers i mean these shows are are
incredibly physical and require
a certain level of energy that i think
even for a theater piece is is uh is a
lot to ask um
you see musicals in general are hard
it's just it's a whole other thing and
and and when they work when now in the
year
those
first two are
classic musicals that are you know all
of the problems have been worked out
when you're working a new show
there's nothing more difficult than
trying to get them it's it's a large
group of people that all have to be
telling the same story and and it's rare
when it happens so when it does it's a
glorious thing but yeah so often they
don't work did and um yeah the producers
require a lot of work shopping was that
an involved process or was that there
the producers was some sort of uh
um
just um a magical thing that
that
and it was a i think it was sort of a
long process to uh you know david
gefford wanting to do it and going after
hal and mel saying nah i don't want to
do that i you know i've thought about it
you know people have asked me over the
years but i don't want to do that i want
let it be this great little cult film
and that enough of that
and then he thought about finally he
convinced him and then he he thought
well i should get some a composer you
know and he went to a few people then he
went to jerry herman who said uh i don't
think i'm right for it but i know a
really good composer and he's he's
actually already written two songs for
it and then he played you know
springtime for hitler and
prisoners of love and so then mel and
and really that was the right thing to
do it had to all come from mel and and
then so he
sat down and and and bancroft his
late great wife y'all would say go
upstairs and write a song
and so eventually and he wrote co-wrote
the book with tom meehan who who helped
him
find his way through the the musical
comedy form
although he had written books to
musicals before you wrote the book to a
show called all american
and the book to uh um
i want to say was archie and mahitabel
he wrote a couple of books
for shows but
uh um this was an adaptation of what was
in an academy award-winning screen right
and you know what works on film doesn't
always work on stage
and so
it was um it and then he finding the
right
director and he went to one person and
it didn't work out and then he went to
mike cochran's and susan strowman who uh
they very successfully had done uh crazy
for you and and mike had done uh um i
want to say me and my girl but
uh and then sadly uh while they were
developing the whole thing and so susan
was going to choreograph and mike was
going to direct it and mike had leukemia
and
and uh
and did not uh survive
and and then uh
susan said i can't go on with this and
mel
talked her into doing it and taking
on the whole thing
and um you know he as she she sort of
has told this story of how he said you
know
um
and during lunch breaks and when you go
home you'll cry and you'll feel badly
but all day long you will
laugh uh i promise you that and
and so in many ways it's difficult as it
was it it
it probably very it helped
therapeutically
yet get through it and and she did you
know some of the best work over korea
yeah and and so then it was just a
matter of
finding the right people and then uh i
met i met mel and anne once before they
came to see me in a neil simon play and
then i was in paris
with my husband and we um we were
staying at the ritz and i went down to
the pool
and um mel and anne were the only two
people in the pool and so i got in and
we talked and then and went upstairs and
then mel was sitting there it was
sitting there floating there i mean he
said i've written a musical version of
the producers and i think you're the
only person to play max pialistock and i
was like oh wow i said
great oh my god
honored and uh and he wanted marty short
to play leo bloom
and then um
marty had just finished doing uh uh um
little me a revival of little me which
he was incredible he wasn't only awarded
and he so he'd been away from his family
for quite a long time and he did not
want to make another commitment like
that and and luckily
someone thought of uh matthew broderick
and suggested matthew
and uh he met with mel and they talked
and and and then that's
the beginning and it could because
nathan that's a year that's a solid year
commitment right when you sign up for
something like that
yes wow
absolutely and and had you know known
matthew before had you certainly not
worked with him but well we had both
provided voices in the lion king oh
sure
the original lion sure isn't that crazy
you have to say that now yeah
yeah
uh and uh matthew yeah matthew was as he
likes to say adult simba
and i
and and i was uh timon the meerkat and
so we we i think we had met you know at
the um press stuff
at the yeah well yeah or the at the
premiere or something i didn't really
know him well i have seen him
i can remember
running into him on the street
when he was doing brighton beach
memories when he made that sort of
very uh impressive debut in the neil
simon play he wanted a tony for that and
and i had stopped him on the street to
say you know how great i thought he was
you know he was very it was very matthew
broderick he was very shy
yeah
and then he ran away so um
yeah so that was sort of how we
really became friends was doing that
show together it was a it was a bonding
experience
[Music]
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
neil simon keeps coming up um and i know
you've done a lot of neil simon plays
did you did you know him were you close
with him yes i did know him i did the
national tour
of the broadway bound
energy
yes no i was the older brother
this was in 1987.
yeah 1987 i i was broke
and i needed to make some money
and i went in and auditioned and i got
this job and i went on the on the road
so i didn't i auditioned for it but i
didn't meet him he was there but i
didn't meet him i didn't meet him until
we opened at the amundsen in los angeles
and he he there was a knock on the door
and it was neil simon so it was it was
like you know there he was
taller than i imagined and with the horn
rim glasses and he was very
kind and and
and and uh that was sort of the
beginning and then we did this play uh
that he wrote called laughter on the
23rd floor
uh a play in which i had been asked to
play one of the comedy writers and then
when we did a reading of it they said
just for the purposes of the reading you
read the sid caesar roll because you
know eventually we'll want a guy who's
like six four and
two hundred pounds
fine okay
and then and then they decided that i
should play it as neil simon said to me
what you what you lack in height you
make up for in anger
so
that was a that was a bonding experience
we went out i got to go out of town with
neil simon play and sort of watch him
craft it and work it and then he i can
remember um
coming in and we were rehearsing and he
was sitting in the audience you know in
a in a seat and he wrote on a yellow
legal pad longhand you know and he's
writing i said well i said hi what are
you writing and he said uh i'm writing a
speech for you actually and uh
he said well we'll maybe we'll put it in
a few days and i said
i said well let me see it i'll put it in
tonight
and then um so he loved this sort of um
enthusiasm
and gopher broke yeah give it to me
we'll do it now
um and so he would always come to me and
he must have changed my entrance
the the scene of this this character
entering into the play
i don't know how many times he rewrote
it and would be he felt free to try
things and give them to me
at the last minute
so um did you ever regret being so
gung-ho initially not at all
oh i loved that it was like i was felt
like i was in the writer's room oh yeah
the show and and uh
so he loved that kind of uh
enthusiasm and uh and so you're a quick
study then nathan you're able to pick up
things like that very apparently yeah i
i have i have i'm fortunate luckily
hopefully that continues yeah get older
but yes i i can i i have a facility wow
um so yeah we did that
and then um
uh well you know eventually we did this
revival of the odd couple
right um
you know when i was when i was a kid i
had
joined what was called the fireside
theater a play of the month club
and the first play that i got um
was the odd couple
his hardbound copy of the odd couple
uh random house you know in the black
and white photos of arthur swope photos
of walter matthau and art carney in the
original cast
and i remember i was very thrilling you
know to get this reading i remember
reading it i was in like i don't know
the sixth grade or something yeah
sticking it in a geography book and
reading it and yeah so um eventually
we've done a had done a uh candidate the
kennedy center honors he had been
honored and i had done
one of the one of the we it was me
christine branski and sid caesar and
christine and i would do speeches from
his plays and then sid caesar would talk
in foreign gibberish
and you know
he killed he just killed yeah yeah um uh
he would just start talking in fake
french or german or italian it's amazing
and then we would go back and then i did
a speech from the odd couple and then
eventually
you know years later he wrote me this
letter and he said you know uh i want
after seeing that i vo i wanted to see
you do the whole thing and
i've held on to the rights and i want
you i want you to do it
and and so and so then that's what sort
of led to this this rival and matthew
was just the obvious your chemistry with
him was so obviously
natural and charming that it was was he
the obvious choice
uh yes yeah
yeah and then you know it didn't hurt
that we had done this little thing
called the producer right sure
but it was a rather terrifying
moment of
when we started because before we even
went into rehearsal
it had sold
21 million dollars worth of tickets oh
my god and and
yeah and i remember matthew was like oh
that's not good
he said that's not good
well that's not good but just because
people have a heightened expectation
expectations were high yeah yeah and are
you playing are you alternating oscar
and felix are you he talked about that
we talked about doing that
and then it was seemed just hard enough
to do the part one right
right so we didn't we didn't wind up
doing the uh what phil hoffman and john
c reilly did true west yeah yeah yeah
because the two of you there doesn't
seem to be a natural certainly
physically it's not oh naturally one of
you is should play one could have gone
you know we could have you know there
was a point we had a lunch and he said
he said you called the jokes and i said
what do you want me to do i said why
don't you i'll i'll play felix
you can play oscar and you know he said
no you know they'll have to change the
cartoon
you know outside on the marquee never
mind
but um no it was uh look it was a thrill
it's such a classic american comedy and
and uh yeah i love it yeah well i i if
all these legends that you've worked
with we're talking about is there anyone
you love you've yet to work with that
you would maybe um
just publicly address
publicly address yeah appeal to them um
is there somebody that you're dying to
work with that you've yet to nathan oh
yeah well okay you know like like de
niro uh-huh yeah or yeah de niro and
scorsese yeah yeah yeah sure maybe maybe
after penny dreadful city of angels and
they see me as this grizzled lapd
detective they might they might consider
me for something but uh how liberating
was that getting to play a role like
that nathan a grizzled lapd detective
well it was uh
it was
fantastic yeah uh john logan is the
writer the creator of the show who i
knew a little bit from the theater
and he sent me an email and said i wrote
this part for you and i hope you'll do
it and uh wow and so it was a real gift
it just came out of the blue and he
you know and i said well you're the only
one
in hollywood who would ever have uh
considered me for this part you know
where i'm you know i'm beating people up
and
pistol whipping kids and and piercing
toast and uh so he uh i said what was it
that inspired this and he said he had
seen me do uh this production of the
iceman comment that i did oh sure with
uh bob falls and brian dennehy yeah so
um
uh yeah eugene o'neill finally paid off
yeah but it was um no it's been it was
it's just been a great great great
experience and and the show it's it's i
can't wait to see you you're beautifully
shot in a really terrific cast
i can't wait and it's um okay so it's
not now on show time
sunday's at 10. they said 10.
um speaking of grizzled detectives
before we go into the lightning round i
i need to ask you because it's one of my
favorite movies and
one of my favorite comedic performances
uh i need to ask you about the bird cage
um because i'm stunned to learn that
after working with george c scott and
doing all this great theater in 1987
you're doing this national tour and
you're having trouble paying bills the
birdcage isn't that much later
um no it's about eight years later
yeah okay well you're right um well how
did how did mike nichols what did he
know you from what had he seen you in
that that led him to cast you it uh uh
originally it was supposed to be steve
martin and robin williams
i didn't know that mike had always
wanted to do an american
remake of laka jafal
he and elaine may who
had
you know they kept in touch but they
they they sort of started to work
together again uh he he she helped him
on a film called wolf which wasn't about
jack nicholson it wasn't a very happy
experience but she had done work on it
on this pre-play for him and then they
decided to really reunite and do
do this um remake of blizzage and
so um steve was going to do it but then
he had another commitment and couldn't
get out of it and so and then robin
decided he had already been in drag for
mrs doubtfire and didn't want to play
that part of uh uh uh albert so
he wanted to play the other part and
then the role of albert opened up and
then and i don't know why but
but for some reason he thought of me
so he came to see me in the neil simon
play laughter on the 23rd floor
and said i'd like to talk to you about a
movie and and um and so that's
how it began
oh my god um
what a dream again i mean all these
moments that i know we're glossing over
them but i i'm now imagining your
childhood and your upbringing and now
how what a thrill it must have been for
these oh yeah well you know bringing uh
you know that my nichols and may uh
album you know to ask them to sign it
just like you know bringing bringing
that copy of the odd couple to the first
rehearsal right and saying
please sign this these are
titans yeah yeah
wow wow um
well well i love it so much i it's
brought me so much joy
all of your work has so this is a thrill
and i'm sorry it's taking so long
there's a lightning round right now this
is going to be quick he's there okay and
then we're done
uh
uh what nathan what is your favorite
nickel for every time i've heard that
it's a lightning round and then you're
working yeah well it's just like life
yeah it's a good metaphor
um
uh what is do you use emojis when you
text
do you are you a texter no okay good
eggs but i don't use emojis never okay
rarely
rarely when you do what what what do you
what would you throw in me a heart
great i'm texting someone i'm i love
yes uh if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
lightning well basketball okay okay did
you were you inspired after seeing the
last dance oh
uh is
were you a fan of
did you watch those games during that
time no oh okay
but i'm loving the documentary oh it's
incredible
fascinating it's such an uh an
astonishing career
yeah what a what an impressive human
being he is um
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be okay
let's say uh enterman's chocolate chip
cookies oh
okay wow a little good
yeah sure and uh and a gallon of milk
okay
okay which would eventually spoil but um
yeah what's what's your uh what's your
favorite movie okay not milk what what's
your oh you you no dairy for you
what no no no it's all right what was
the next question what's your favorite
movie of all time
my favorite movie of all time
that's really nice
let me amend that um the most
a comfort movie one that you just brings
you joy you're in quarantine now you
want to um you want to be comforted i
would say um i want to be comforted eh
well like yeah it's something maybe from
childhood so i think of comfort yeah
because there's many there's so many
yeah i know i'm often shamed for this
question well yeah my favorite movie is
you know that's you want to talk black
and white or do you want to talk color
i'll talk about anything happening
you know what i find is a comforting
movie um uh off the top of my head is uh
um pocketful of miracles so george cucor
made uh this it was a remake of uh
the damon runyon story of apple annie uh
and the gangster um uh and it stars uh
betty davis and glenn ford
and and people like edward everett
horton
great these great character actors and
great names peter falk in this hilarious
i think he got an oscar nomination oh
wow as this uh uh you know gangster who
works with glenn ford
okay i'm i'm gonna i get so many good
recommendations now uh thank you
selfishly pocket full of miracles um
alec baldwin almost left across the
table and throttled me when i asked him
that question
how can you ask me that
one one movie how could you ask me
what the [ __ ] are you thinking well um
he he'd leap across and throttle you for
a parking space let alone
not even name just one [ __ ] movie
it doesn't take much um okay uh this uh
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
who would it be three huh oh this one
three people dead or alone
we can come back to it we can do it
another time and have dinner with
yeah or a lunch
something more casual
oh
oh man well
well you know i just you can't even
um
let's see
uh
we don't have to let's skip it let's
skip it
let's skip it that you may not this one
might be skipped too who's your favorite
muppet
do you have a favorite muppet did you
watch the muppets in the 70s
you know what's the bear oh
that's true
and the worse the jokes are the funnier
he is
uh
what a great character to play um if you
uh if you could have a uh be
reincarnated as a non-human animal if
that is what happens to us afterwards
well i guess uh i guess uh meerkat
of course i would come back
would uh yeah it would seem only
appropriate to come back meerkat and
they they i what
what i've seen on the documentaries they
seem to have a nice life they all look
out for each other it's a good beautiful
right yeah always look yeah they're
looking around yes sometimes they come
in there they put their arms around each
other yes they're very sociable they're
very so
and and i'd imagine you're already very
huge in the meerkat community
um if you know how many letters i've got
um and would you rather be called
unattractive or unfunny nathan
if somebody were to call you either of
them i've been called both
oh well
uh uh would i rather i'd rather be
called unattractive than i'm funny yeah
um
is there is there a golden girl that you
most identify with dorothy blanche rose
or sophia
arthur yeah dorothy you are a dorothy
yeah
um yeah a little bee
and would you rather have a dog a dog or
a cat as a pet he came to see the
producer a dog of course i'm a doctor
um the arthur she came to see the
producers and she walked in you know
she's very tall yes you'll recall yes
and she said she looked at me and she
went
nathan
all i can say is
and then does she leave she's got to
make an exit then she punched me right
in the mouth i don't know why
she was funny
it's a very dorothy thing to do um
uh god that must have been there must
have been just a steady stream of uh
well-wishers and
oh it's amazing
yeah
yeah
from barbara walters to kofi annan
queen
strange people you wouldn't expect at
the producers alan greenspan
you're kidding yeah uh uh you know al
gore
oh everybody came to see it oh my god
yeah do you enjoy that nathan i've
always wondered um
and and this is actually good for me to
know personally next time i see you in a
play
do you enjoy that or is it like let me
get out of here let me take my costume
off take and go home
well it depends it depends on honestly
if it will make you do all the work
then i'd rather they leave quickly um
but you know to meet some of those those
people
i mean i don't mind doing all the work i
get it people get odd backstage or
nervous and and yet they want to somehow
pay their respects and right right and
um and but you know
um
like i can remember going back to like
guys and dolls i remember um you know
these are names that people the the
audience won't remember but it was a man
named sheldon leonard who was a great
character actor in films and then who
went on to become a very successful
television producer he did things like
the danny thomas showed the um the dick
van dyke show um
and he was
but he in in films he always played
uh a gangster you know he's in the movie
of uh of guys and dolls where he plays
harry the horse oh oh okay
oh my god and he came back and he was
very impeccably dressed and suntan you
know he was a you know west coast
television
and he was he was so charming so uh
lovely and i just i like moments like
that i remember or uh meeting him saying
i love what you did with this show and
then or there was um uh you know meeting
harvey corman
the producers and saying how much he
loved a piece of physical business you
know that these people had you know you
idolized and sure and or carol burnett
coming back and just you know she got
and getting really emotional and saying
it reminds me of what
musical comedy used to be you know it
was like a going to a great party and
you and me
you know that that stuff you'll always
remember those those those kinds of
people sure yeah no i i sometimes i feel
sometimes the person is so um it carries
so much weight that i feel bad for them
you know because everyone's
crowding them or paying it yeah a little
too um
to to in their face um
i remember doing a play at williamstown
and
ruth bader ginsburg was friends with
somebody in the play
an actress in the play and um
doug sills you must know doug sills was
it was in the play
and she came backstage and you know
wasn't really saying anything but
everybody coming up and taking pictures
and i
doug said you should go say hi and i i i
i i
i felt bad you know um
but that must be yeah yeah must be a
thrill uh
okay well
listen to just people going up and
whispering please don't die yes yeah
here's no vitamins
yeah yeah
i have a great nutritionist if you want
my number okay
um well you had said earlier that that
uh a great line that i won't forget what
you lack
neil simon what you lack in height you
make up for in anger and and
i i i think i i would say what you like
in height you make up for in in just
charisma and talent and humor and i've
always been such a big fan of yours i i
i'm so grateful that you did this uh
with me today nathan oh thank you well
i'm a big fan of you
and uh so it was a great pleasure it was
mine thank you i really appreciate it
i'm sorry it went a little long
uh but i uh i look forward to no problem
i look forward to seeing you backstage
one day
absolutely
all right
paying respects thank you thank you
justin
take care stay safe
[Music]
well that just happened happened
what do you think pretty good right now
a little higher well that higher oh that
happened well well it's sort of like uh
i don't know i mean he's got a there's a
there's a refined kind of classy quality
he's a dame he's
dame lane
dame lane he's that's yeah he really is
uh in in he should he should be knighted
because he's a man
but i think it i think it's
oh
you got damned i don't know do they get
knighted too no i don't think so i think
that's just for men which doesn't seem
fair i i damn you
i don't know we should shorty sir ben
kingsley sir alec guinness sir nathan
lane
have we had but it should be dame nathan
lane
has a knight been a a guest of the
pokemon no
don't scoff well who knows maybe a
knight will want to come on i'm not
saying it'll never happen but who
could it have been
you know
god i wish alan rickman was still alive
not because i wanted him to be on the
show no i mean i mean of the guests
we've had i think 70 i think this might
be our 70th guest today
of those 70 guests
who
were you confused about them
being uh potentially being a knight uh i
guess jerry could be a knight jerry i'm
just cal
by the way i hope he's not listening to
this
thanks for being so incredulous about
the prospect of me
being a knight you know i i can search
your sir sir jerry that's funny maybe
one day by the way if i had power
tonight so i would make him a knight me
too you don't bother with my cheerio
cuddle
would knight the craziest people i would
like
oh man it'd be so fun to have that power
i would do a lot of ironic knights
i would nightstir mix a lot
sir sir makes a lot you have to calm sir
sir
that's funny uh yeah he i don't i wonder
if actually no nathan has been knighted
but like there's certain things he
is yeah deserving of knighthood or dame
hood um
i think just based on the birdcage
you know like i would say just that one
performance and some people have so few
performances that they've ever done you
think about uh um my god jim
uh oh no oh no blankie on his name from
the conversation and the godfather fredo
john casale john cassell gazelle was in
five movies yeah and they're all iconic
yeah
yeah i wish i'd seen the producers the
producers feels like one of those two
plays that um
that people are gonna be talking about
50 years from now you know i regret that
like i was there exactly i regret it and
all those people went like kofi and none
and all the dignitaries joking about
that kofi annan and barbara walters
and
i mean copenhagen more impressive but i
mean like barbara walters went uh but i
that i regret in true west with phil
hoffman yeah chauncey riley
that's like talk about once now it's not
like i had an opportunity to go those
tickets were like hundreds of dollars
and i had no money i know so
um you had money you didn't have excuse
me that's true i did have my uh you're
probably working a lot no i think i
could have gone i remember thinking like
i need to go
it's gonna be on i just kept delaying it
because it was that's that's when my
like
frugality gets in the way of i could
like seeing the producers with that cast
with broderick and nathan lane that's
like
that's five hundred dollars well spent i
would think hamilton too i mean i
my
hey you saw hamilton i did eventually
but the first time i could have seen it
at the when i was workshopping the
public and uh i was like yeah i'd rather
watch football this sunday afternoon
okay yeah different interests i missed
football john cassell was in the deer
hunter dog day afternoon have you seen
the dog afternoon no god is it the
godfather deer hunter the godfather and
the conversation five movies i never saw
the conversation it's iconic i've seen
three of his five movies though wow
that's pretty cool you celebrate that's
the majority of those five movies yes
yeah yeah and he was so he had no old
dogs in his resume
no no no he had no movie 43 in his
resume
no only uh greats he was only in grades
that's amazing talk about icabi he's
like he's john cassell yeah yeah let's
get back to nathan lane oh right our
current icon um yes yeah so i think it's
like this and isn't it fun to like put
me back to his voice
[Laughter]
you just had a stroke and you forgot the
last like five minutes of conversation
oh yeah it's more like that like that
well i wanted a cutting point in case me
she wanted to cut out all this wait when
the interview started uh did you
was there some friction because he
seemed a little testy with you in the
beginning uh was he mad that you hadn't
seen a show yeah okay yeah i think i
think so
yeah he was mad because he was like what
am i doing here if not to talk about the
show yes it was also like we're gonna
talk about all these different things
because we started talking about
things that weren't his show and i think
right away that's that kind of troubled
him that made him unsettled now in my
defense you didn't know he was i did i
did not know we were not told by the
booking agency thank you uh and yeah i
had really no idea so it was an innocent
mistake but one that i think i don't
know if i ever overcame
i think you did i think yeah there was
it was a little testy at the beginning
and it was a little testy at the end i
want to get to that okay but so it was
bookended with some testiness
but i thought
you you were pretty deft in segwaying
away from the thing he was there to
promote and into
a more general conversation about his
life and his childhood and
he uh he really opened up i thought and
he be and he seemed very comfortable
talking about his life his childhood his
career and he uh he didn't seem testy
throughout you know i i sh i should have
asked him if he was uh
if he was ever making love with anyone
and they said and and they stopped
abruptly and i could tell you weren't
listening to me just and he was like hey
what's up what are you doing and they
and they said oh i'm sorry i should stay
in my
lane is that stupid
your eyes yeah i was just thinking of
that joke your eyes glazed over when i
was talking
can i always tell when you're not
listening yeah really yeah wow that's
that's good you're intuitive and you
know me really well um
yeah uh what were you saying
i was saying i was complimenting your
i know your skills
and your ability to uh get him to open
up about his life yeah he's opening up
about his child i got back into the
right lane that was funny you were like
so would you say you had a very normal
standard upbring suburban upbringing in
new jersey and he was like oh
no no
no no no perish the thought his
upbringing sounds really crazy intense
yeah intense yeah he went through a lot
he went through a lot so you know what's
i was just oh i want to get back to this
but i just realized that remember john
lovitz is actor i'm an actor yes isn't
he a little bit like that like the real
version of uh yeah yeah he's like the
more muted yes like i can picture him
wearing uh like a hugh hefner type yeah
like a smoking robe like a smoking
jacket like velvety right suede or like
scarlet colored robe yeah do you have
any
yeah okay it's funny though like it's
like hugh hefner is just such a
heterosexual
it's funny i wonder if anyone's ever
compared nathan lane to hugh hefner
but amazing what he overcame
though father and the i know the manic
depressive mother i know it
in a way it's it's it's crazy that that
wasn't an alcoholic beverage that's
something so tragic like such a
difficult thing could lead to
him providing so much joy to people
isn't that amazing it's almost like it's
almost like he needed that type of pain
in order to
um completely retreat from it and hide
in these well brilliantly hide in these
characters charlie chaplin had a similar
life and and be beginning and i think he
used comedy it that that tragic
upbringing very like dickensian of
charlie chaplin's one of the few books i
read was his autobiography that led to
him bringing so much joy i mean like
you think about what we're experiencing
now we're in a depression a recession
and obviously we're in very troubled
times
you think about the way he entertained
the country the world um in the 30s the
20s 30s
yeah and and he with like a real but and
there's also real like playful innocence
about i would say both of those two guys
williams too nathan lane and yeah and
chaplain that yeah they had so much
darkness in their past but
they had such a
playful
spirit i wonder how that's possible like
i wonder if it's because they
in nathan's case i think he had to rely
on that in order to bring light into any
sort of buoyancy that just as like a
survival mechanism for his family to
kind of like keep his mother and brother
maybe
entertain you know to keep the
ship afloat i mean he doesn't seem that
buoyant as a person no no but i'm just
thinking as a performer yeah what he's
capable of that he's capable of that
kind of
um
levity and
that brilliant levity
he made a lot of um
people old references
and i knew you didn't know any of them
and he'd be like of course uh franklin
franbourne and
from a fanny hearst novel and you'd be
like ah yes grant wadlow
yeah flynn bronson's yeah you're like oh
yes classic which he learned
incidentally from
patricia
cromington
but i think in your defense with someone
like him
as potentially dishonest as it may be to
pretend like you know the references
you have to just stay out of his way
because it's an interesting moment he
also tells such
um interesting rich stories right he has
he's lived such an exactly fascinating
life that you kind of just want to get
out of that guy's way you don't want to
you don't want him to get hung up on you
the the audience
exactly exactly yeah but that was good
you stayed out of his way yeah but
you're right i mean it is like that's
that's an interesting thing is that
on on paper
and and like just out of context that's
a dishonest moment to be like uh-huh
just to be like to be going along with
some story of like people oh you know uh
frank pambroy and like uh-huh but but
it's worth it
exactly it's what would you call that uh
mental the end justifies the means
yeah i guess so in terms of it's for the
greater good of the story of of the
interview my experience yeah yeah i
forgive you thanks
thanks shorties um
he uh but he made me want to watch that
movie i i'm curious to i don't think i
ever will but uh
which one the one that he recommends i
don't remember oh yeah
um he
so maybe it didn't make me want to watch
that movie maybe that's phony uh it was
so funny when watch it when you got
excited he brought up he brought up
surprisingly the uh the last dance the
michael jordan documentary
were like injected with enthusiasm
you're like oh my well guys it came on
the heels of richard corningwell and
like all these people i didn't know
stanley dubrinsky
oh michael jordan you were like have you
been loving it yeah and you're like did
you
did you watch him when he played were
you did you watch those games
yeah so i'll be you okay so did you
watch those games when they were on did
you watch michael jordan play live now
[Laughter]
oh my god
and you're like okay
so the lighting round was amazing that
was amazing yeah he all of a sudden
became so
like get me out of here
the whole interview he seemed so game to
talk about his career and then the
lightning round came and he was like
are you kidding well you know i think
what's my favorite emoji well i think it
is defense and you're like what three
people doing on dinner with he was like
oh god oh yeah he did three people that
have never met oh god okay
yeah um and you and then but then you
panicked and you're like never mind
they're mine
we'll come back to it don't worry about
it
well in his defense you're like it's a
dumb question don't worry about it well
well again it's like a different way of
doing pro promotional stuff like if i
was a 65 year old right now
i probably wouldn't want to be like
what's your favorite emoji yeah you know
who's your favorite muppet i'd be like i
don't know who
this is
i'm here to talk about me
yeah i think you'd
maybe i mean you're getting the icon you
would be into it yeah icon me you might
not be into it though
if in the next 25 years i've become an
icon somehow
i might have no patience for that kind
of icon it's funny to imagine it's funny
do you am i wearing a robe uh
i think you would like not give a [ __ ]
and wear uh yeah cause you wear some
crazy [ __ ] in quarantine you'd be i
think you'd wear what you wearing
quarantine
you icon you and quarantine you would
dress similarly
i think you'd wear like a little like
rabbit face mask what is that thing you
have with the ears oh that's just a
headband to keep my hair up yeah
let's read a letter okay
sarah s subject please make christian
watch all the movies what yeah in caps
wow hi justin christian maggie and team
oh um i love your podcast thank you
sarah and by far the best part is the
banter between you and christian i now
love tuesdays i wonder if she hated them
before or how she felt about them before
i enjoy your affinity with bud light
seltzer whoa but you both don't have but
you both don't have to like it that's
funny funny there's such a that's
your pot has been a saving grace through
this pandemic thanks sarah i've been
working from home i'm grateful and i
miss people very much listening to you
has made me feel far less lonely i
haven't had a hug since february
it's taking i don't i have i had a nice
hug the other day it's taking a toll but
i have a great distance support system
that's great i'm gonna make it i've
returned to earlier quarantine episodes
and it's funny to hear you talk about
being quarantined for 14 whole days i
would say ignorance is bliss but that's
what got us here
it's funny may i suggest a present-day
quarantine check-in just to see how
views have changed we should we should
should do that to the point i am often
shocked that christian hasn't seen many
classic films most recently a clockwork
orange yeah yeah i'm surprised you
haven't seen that
although i took have you ever take a
film course at colgate no
uh i don't think they offered film
courses over colgate oh it's faster at a
good film department i i i think that's
where i saw it uh
i i also went through a phase where i
was like i tried to watch as many of
those classics like john cazale movies
uh please make a list and have them
watch them i will say in my defense over
the last couple years i have
tried to um start crossing those
classics off my list so
i finally after that long last saw
movies like in the last couple years
movies like deer hunter
good fellas dear underwear good fellas
like a lot of movies magnolia there are
movies that i've been meaning to see
forever uh dr strangelove i recently saw
so but but yes um i have a long way to
go there a bunch i need to see too uh
back to sarah
thank you for brightening pandemic
tuesdays and making me laugh sarah s oh
jesus would you rather great
would you rather live a year in total
isolation in a romantic paradise
no contact with the outside world or
spend i've that's always been a total
isolation in a romantic paradise
yeah that'd be that'd be tough because
it'd be wrong would be right there only
if you were with somebody but there
wouldn't be any other romantic people
around you i don't think so
in total but why would it be romantic
exactly
would you rather live a year in total
isolation in a romantic paradise i mean
total isolation sounds like total
isolation but if it's with a lover
that'd be like you know uh
it'd be
blue lagoon right it'd be awesome
no contact with the outside world or
or spend six months in the same romantic
paradise with all of your exes and their
partners they are all in loving
relationships in this scenario and you
have no partner i see so the first one
is you are with a lover a romantic i
think no total isolation
no contact with the outside world or
spent six months in the same romantic
paradise
with all of your exes and their i don't
understand the first half
hmm
okay i think we have to make a
distinction here so let's say it's
total isolation no people
no other no stranger i guess so okay but
but it's a beautiful paradise
god would that get lonely i mean like
let you know tom hanks was on that if
that's the case if it's just me in a
beautiful location or six months or six
months i would definitely do this six
months not only is it half the time
but i'm i'm close with some of my me too
and the ones that i'm not i'd like to
get closer with i would get over
whatever weirdness i felt about seeing
them with their current mother i would
get over that quickly i think especially
if you were all it would really bond all
of you and it'd be like oh you know
if ever there were if there were any
lingering like
sentiments of like
yeah you could work through a lot of i
would like that actually yeah i would
definitely pick even if the first one
what if the first one was just you and a
lover for a year that would be pretty
fun that would but
i think it'd get here's the thing a year
with anybody yeah is is
too much of a good thing is not good so
like you know you don't want to go on a
year-long vacation because then it stops
being a vacation that's true then it
becomes like survival right uh i would
definitely pick this section i would do
i you know i think i would also pick the
six months one with the um
x's even if i did have a partner yeah on
the one year long one i think i would
either way pick six months now that i
think about it'd be really nice actually
to get like for the exes that i'm not
close with it'd be really nice to like
get close with them and their partners
or not nice you you might really not get
along with them but yeah interesting
it'd be interesting you'd figure things
out i think and even if you didn't like
them it's six months also you're in
paradise and like any any issues that
they had or you had i'm sure they would
pale in comparison to like we need to
get fresh water
and we have to figure out how to survive
and work together it sounds really cool
anyway thank you sarah that was iconic
oh what an icon and um thanks for
suggesting that movie list is going to
get on it yep um and suggest some for me
there are some stanley kubrick movies
i've never seen i you know god i don't
think i've seen
dr strangelove
okay have you seen passive glory great
movie no
um and i haven't seen so many movies i
know it's i know i can't do that but um
okay all right well i haven't seen any
of nathan lane's top 200 favorite movies
probably you know what you'd love is
barton fink we've talked about this oh
i've been brothers
um
okay we're gonna do that great idea
sarah and uh really good would you
rather six months with the exes i'm
taking it and thank you to the iconic
nathan lane thank you
uh and i feel like one of us should be
taking a bow now he's such a like
thespian we should end this in some
regal
we can because we're not iconic that's
true that's true all we can do is the
show all we can do is say stay safe and
we will talk to you next week whether
you're an icon or not
a little
uh yeah thanks everyone
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
a life is short is hosted by me justin
long not an icon it's co-hosted by
another non-icon
christian yeah yeah yeah i thought you
wanted me to stay on my own
and then when i did you looked
frustrated it's also produced by megan
monaco senior producers michelle miesh
lans audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall louie
and hernan lopez for wondering bye icons
[Music]
eye cover thing
you look crazy mustache and like little
like owl glasses
you're just noticing him
why do i look crazy you look like
you look like um
like like some sort of like what
like creature in the wilderness
yeah you're not a creature like a gopher
something that's like who's been like
hibernating like a bobcat or something a
bobcat
don't
flatter yourself
look at how you're drinking
all right so eat some more whipped cream
oh my god
you